- Hi, I'm Stephanie.
- Hi, I'm Diane.
- And we play sisters in the
new Disney film, "Encanto",
coming to theaters this November 24th.
We are very excited to
share this film with you.
Today, we're going to be making...
- [Both] Arepas con queso!
- We're gonna be competing
to see whose are better.
They're gonna be mine.
- Mine.
- We're gonna be judged by
Vanessa from "Pero Like".
Let's party.
(Latin music)
We clearly wore the
right sleeves for this.
- Yep, yeah we did.
- So.
- Oh, you put the water in first.
- I'm just doing what feels
natural and instinctual to me.
- Okay, organic.
- And since I am
Colombian and you are too,
these are gonna be great.
- That's right
- Because it's in our blood.
- That's right.
I remember my mother, I think
doing this with her hands.
Just for the bare hands.
- Really?
- Yeah, the whole process. Just her bare
- Why don't you just dip in there?
- My mom didn't wear these sleeves.
(laughs)
- My dad makes these almost
every Christmas and they're
delicious, you know?
And they're only like
four inches around, right?
So you feel like, oh, well
I've only had one arepa,
and then by the time you're done, you've,
- You've become an arepa.
- Okay, this is looking really good.
- Wow, this is great.
- I mean this is very
simple ingredients, right?
This is cornmeal, salt,
water. Well, in the film,
almost every character
has magical powers, right?
- Right.
- You've got a magical power.
My character doesn't, it's fine.
It's fine. It's not a big deal. It's fine.
- But she finds her magic.
- Sure, sure sure.
And my mom in the film,
- Our mother-
- Her magical power is healing
people through the power of
food, which I think is
such a beautiful metaphor.
- Isn't it beautiful?
- Because so many people
have memories around food,
traditions around food.
I am starting to sweat a little bit, okay.
So the next step is
you take out your masa,
- Eso!
- and you put it on your counter.
You shape it into a eight inch log.
- This is where your hands come in. Wow.
- We're measuring. I brought my own ruler.
- Wait until my parents see me making
arepas with a ruler. So we've
come a long way, you guys.
So you make it with like a log.
Now, do I cut it with the,
[Both] with the ruler?
Okay.
You know, I called my mother before,
before we came on the show.
- What'd she say?
- She said that my dad would make,
she said my dad would make them.
And sh- they would make a bunch
in the beginning of the week.
And then at the end of the
week, on the weekend, right.
It would get all the
leftovers from the week.
So like beans and rice and chicharron
and chorizo and whatever, what have you.
And it would make a big calentao, right?
And then it would have
it with a little arepa.
- Aw, that sounds so nice!
- Isn't it cute?
- Okay, so now Diane's beating me.
- Sorry, okay, we'll go-
- It's fine!
- No, we'll go together!
- It's a competition. It's a competition.
- But like,
- So just go ahead.
- All right, you know, I'm just going
to make all my bolitas,
And then we go to the next step.
This is my first time
making them by the way.
- Is it really?
- Yeah. Is it yours?
- No.
- Oh.
(ding)
- You put like a hefty tablespoon
of cheese in there, right?
Like personally,
I would probably put this
entire thing of cheese in here
if I could fit it in, but I can't.
- Right here. Boom.
Oh no, no.
- That's pretty good.
- Oh, gosh.
Oh dear.
- You're doing great.
- Thanks.
- It's good to encourage other people.
When they're cooking
dishes for the first time,
you don't want people
to get in their heads
and not be able to make things
because they see somebody
else doing really well.
- Wait, so you, so you do this.
Oh, okay. Yeah. Aha!
- Yeah, like that.
- I feel like I almost should have mushed
this arepa mix a little better.
- It looks good.
- Yeah. Yeah.
But I'm just wondering
what would have, wow.
You're frying yours already. Okay.
- Here we go.
- It's fine. It's fine.
It's not it's because I waited for you.
I'm not waiting for you anymore.
I'm just going to go ahead.
- You can pan fry. You
can deep fry, I guess,
if you really want to go for it.
- There's also like those air fryers.
- Air frying an arepa is the most Gen Z
possible thing ever.
- It's very Gen Z. I
remember a lot of this,
pero it's not working for me.
- It's like that, like this,
and then like patting it,
like you pet it, like a pet,
like a little baby's butt.
(baby's cry)
- Ooh.
- Like a little baby butt!
- Little baby butt.
- And then you fry them
roughly three and a half,
four minutes on each side.
- Oh my God. I forgot this part.
Shite. Oh. Can I say that? Sorry.
- We're also making toppings for these.
I'm going to make an avocado mash.
- And I'm going to make a kale chorizo.
My friends would be like, "Que es kale?"
"Que es kale? Pero que es eso?"
- What do you think the
key to a good arepa is?
- Amor.
(harp plays)
I'm serious.
- I'm laughing because I
was going to say queso.
- Well, you're right.
- Yeah.
- I think that anything made with love
is like going to be better.
And it's such an easy dish
and it's also not expensive.
- No.
- Right? None of this is expensive.
Like anybody can make it in a pinch.
You can have it with anything.
You can have it with something salty.
You can have it with something sweet.
Like you can make chocolate-
chocolate completo with this.
You dip this in the
chocolate - oh my goodness.
So fricking good.
- They're not expensive to make.
So when there is a gen Z arepa restaurant
that opens and they're
charging $12 for an arepa,
don't do it. Don't buy them.
- Wow. Mine are going to be
a little on the greasy side.
- Let's keep going and do our toppings.
So now we're making our toppings.
Mine is an avocado mash,
avocado, cilantro, crushed red
pepper, lime, and then salt.
- So oil. First of course,
cause we're going to
have to sautee our stuff.
I'm just going to start
garlic. You need garlic.
Don't want to touch it.
Cause then your hands
smell like garlic all day.
- Wow.
- That smells, that
smells good immediately.
- Yeah. I know.
I was worried that my deodorant
was going to make this
shirt smell funky and no.
- No. That's going to be the garlic.
A hundo percent.
- They're going to have
to give me this shirt now.
- This looks like something
I would eat by itself.
- Do you like cooking?
Do you like cooking kale in, in like this?
- I do. I like a kale saute,
I like a kale sauteed
in, a little olive oil,
maybe a little ghee.
- What's ghee?
- You don't know what ghee is?
- No.
Oh my God. Ghee is clarified butter.
It's so good!
- Okay. Clarified butter.
- It's really delicious.
I like a little bit of
avocado chunk in the mash.
You know what I mean?
Like I don't like
guacamole when you get it.
And it's like thin baby food.
- I love chorizo.
- Me too.
- I eat way too much
chorizo. But I love it.
- Is that possible?
- I love chorizo.
There's not enough chorizo in the world.
- When you taste your
food, do you taste it
and like keep mixing
it with the same spoon?
- You know what? I don't taste my food.
It's a surprise for everyone.
(laughs)
- I'm not gonna lie.
I feel like you might
win based on the topping,
which not sure it's fair, but.
I'm gonna let you have it.
- No, but I think with arepas,
it's the arepa that counts.
If the arepa is not there,
- We'll see what Vanessa thinks.
- Adding the rest.
- What else? Oh, that's right.
You have more parts?
- I got-
- Should I just stand
here and eat my topping?
- Yeah. Just eat your topping.
This is salt. Apple cider vinegar.
Ooh, whoa.
Here we go. And miel de abeja.
A little
- [Both] honey.
- This is what's going to
make it sweet obviously,
because this is a sweet kale chorizo.
- It looks good!
- It's Awesome.
And I love the little
shaved garlic like that.
- Yeah. Did you do that?
Did you cut your garlic shaved?
- Yeah I learned in prison.
- It's really good. (laughs)
- With the Italian.
The Italians taught me the real nice
little razor sharp thin.
Then shout out to Goodfellas.
Ray Liotta what up?
- I feel like we're ready.
- Let's plate.
Mmmm! They came out so cute.
- Awesome.
- I'm really proud of myself.
I feel like our families
would be proud of us.
- Oh, absolutely.
- Right?
- Yeah. My dad can't believe
it. Can't believe it!
- That's ah, pretty good.
That looks pretty good.
Your parents do that?
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah. Mine too.
- That's where my sense of like,
wanting to be perfect comes from.
- Mmm, very much like your
character in the film.
- And very much like my, my character.
- Yeah.
- Wow!
- Ready for judging!
- Wait, is that how-?
- Vanessa, come here
before Diane replates!
Hurry up!
- Was it supposed to be plated like that?
- You eat with your eyes.
- Based on how they look
alone. I'm not going to lie.
I would house that entire plate.
That looks absolutely delicious to me.
- I would eat this first and
then I would move on to my main
dish. You know what I mean?
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I could see that. I mean,
if we were at an arepa restaurant
and both of these came to the table,
I would not be mad at either one.
- No, me neither.
- Vanessa!
- [Vanessa] Hello. How are you guys?
- [Stephanie] I'm excited.
- [Vanessa] So am I, I
haven't had breakfast.
They both look good. Okay.
This one looks really fancy.
Como, un desayuno bueno.
I'm just going to go for it.
Ooh. I like the cheese.
- Okay.
- [Vanessa] Con guacamole
esta. Ahora, este, what is it?
- [Diane] It's sweet kale and chorizo.
- Ooh.
- [Stephanie] That looks so
good. I'm not going to lie.
That looks so good.
- [Vanessa] So first impressions.
I love the fanciness of this one,
but this flavor is like really intense.
And I like, I love that.
It's so different. Pero...
my favorite one has to be this one.
- [Stephanie] Ayyy!
- [Diane] What?
- [Vanessa] It's just like, I don't know.
It feels more like un arepa.
- Those arepas are bomb.
- [Diane] Can I go for it?
- [Vanessa] Yeah.
You guys filled that.
- [Stephanie] We are
excited for you guys to see
arepas con queso on the big screen in
"Encanto", this November 24th.
We're so, so excited to share our movie
and our culture with you.
We can't wait.
- [Diane] Hope you love it.
- Oh yes!
(folk latin music)